PETE LEPAGE: Sounds good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, welcome everybody.
And thanks for joining us for
another installment of "Behind
The Divs," a look behind the
scenes of one of the great new
Chrome experiments.
I'm Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And joining me today, we've got
two of the engineers who
are behind building
of Chrome Racer.
So with that I want to introduce
Michael Anthony and
Andy Thelander who are joining
us from LA, right?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
ANDY THELANDER: That's right.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Well, welcome guys.
Why don't you introduce
yourselves?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Thanks.
Yeah, I'm Michael.
I'm a technical director
at Active Theory.
And on Racer I coded the car's
gameplay and the across device
communication.
ANDY THELANDER: And,
hey, I'm Andy.
I'm the creative technologist
at Active Theory.
And I did the finalization,
[INAUDIBLE], tweaking the UI,
[INAUDIBLE] and animation,
just all the OS stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
Well, this is a really
neat experiment.
And congrats on getting it shown
at Google I/O where it
was launched for
the first time,
especially in the keynote.
And you guys just published an
"HTML5 Rocks" article on sort
of how you built it.
So today we're going to take
a look at some of that.
But as you guys are watching
at home, if you have
questions, if there are things
that you want to ask either
Michael or Andy, feel free to
post them to Google Moderator.
The link will show up
periodically throughout our
show, just there on the
bottom of the screen.
And you can post those.
The link for those who are
watching is goo.gl/JFu7J.
But I want to jump into one of
the first questions that I had
for you guys.
Walk me through a little bit
about what happens when a
player joins a game.
So, like, I go, I grab my phone,
and I say connect.
What happens when you get
all those players
connecting to a game?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So when one
person creates the game, it
hits the central App Engine
server and that gives you the
code that you need to share
with the other players.
PETE LEPAGE: So when you say
code, what do you mean code?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So that five
character code that the other
players have to did punch in.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So that's so that you
know which users are
connecting to which.
We're not talking about HTML5,
or JavaScript code or
anything like that.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Right, yeah.
It's just a key that you punch
in with your keyboard on the
other devices.
So there's a bunch of servers
all over the world.
And there's a few in American
and some in Europe.
And basically, when your device
hits the app, it will
ping the servers and choose
the closest location.
And that's going to be
your relay server.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So when the
other devices punch in that
initial game code, they connect
to that same relay
server that the host is on.
And then the host shares which
track has been selected.
So all the devices render the
track, and they build the
track out, and show the
appropriate portion.
And then, you get the ready,
set, go screen and you tap
when everybody's
ready to play.
It slides up, and
the game begins.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So let's dive in a little bit
more on what's happening with
each of those steps
technically.
So when you do that initial
connection to figure out what
server is the fastest one,
what are you doing there?
Why are you trying to figure
out which one's the fast--
well, obviously we know
performance matters.
But what's the sort of
steps on figuring
out which one's closest?
How are you doing that?
MICHAEL ANTHONY:
So [INAUDIBLE]
when the site loads, actually,
during the preloader.
It basically sends a ping to
each relay that's available.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So I believe
it's about 8 relays.
Ed Goose at PA Consulting
actually built all the App
Engine stuff.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, cool.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: And
he set it all up.
So it'll actually give the app
a list of all the relays that
are available, and it's
a few in each region.
There's hundreds of relays, but
it only serves up the two
with the lowest load
at the moment.
And it'll give you the
list of relays.
And it'll do a bunch of pings.
And it will choose the
median, obviously.
Because accounting for all the
different network factors
it'll ping each server a few
times and choose the median.
And then the one with the lowest
ping, which is usually
about 50 milliseconds, will be
the one that's selected.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Cool.
So once you've selected that
initial server that you're
connecting to, and then the
other phones or tablets,
whatever the devices are, they
know which one you're
connecting to based on that.
And they're all sitting
roughly in
the same space, right?
So you know that they're
probably all on the same
network and that
kind of thing.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yup.
PETE LEPAGE: Now do you think
that there are HTML5 APIs that
would have been helpful
for this?
Do you think the network
performance API would have
been useful?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: I mean, WebRTC
would have been ideal.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, right.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: But I mean,
that's just making it's way to
desktop right now.
So it's a bit of a ways
off on mobile.
I mean, the difference between
WebRTC and WebSockets is that
with WebSockets the devices
don't communicate directly
with each other.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: You start with
the relay server, which
then relays that message out
to all the other players.
With WebRTC they would actually
be able to directly
communicate with each other.
PETE LEPAGE: So you're using
WebSockets then for each
device to connect to that main
server, and then you're
sending the data out between
all of them.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: Right, OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So in essence
they're all connected to each
other, but not without
a little help.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
So once you've got them all
connected and you've
established sort of, OK, we've
got these three or however
many devices that we want to
play with, how do you figure
out how big your track
should be?
And what are you using
to build that track?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So what it'll
do is it will look at the
total widths of all the devices
and it'll look at the
height of the smallest device.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Obviously,
those are the kind of
dimensions that the tracks
have to fit in.
If it was any taller than
the smallest device, it
would look cut off.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So then once
it gets all those dimensions
and it'll figure out sort of
what each phone is and where
it needs to sit in
the lineup--
and by line up I mean
when players join--
they're assigned a specific
joining order.
And s when it gives you the
colored screens and tells you
you need to reshuffle your phone
to fit in this order.
And that's set up deliberately
so you get that rainbow color.
So it'll always start with blue
and end with red, and it
will add colors in the middle,
yellow and green and orange.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Now do the players get added in
the order that they type in
their code or is it
sort of random?
ANDY THELANDER: So it's
based on the color.
So if player one joins,
he'll be blue.
If player two joins,
he'll be red.
And if player one leaves
and then comes back,
he'll be blue again.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: And then those
join in between those
two, they get situated in
between those two colors.
So the next player would
be yellow and then
green and then orange.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So player one's always going
to be on the front.
And player two's always going
to be on the back.
And everybody else will
fit in the middle.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yup.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, cool.
Now when I was reading through
the "HTML5 Rocks" article that
you guys wrote, you ended up
using, I think it was,
Paper.js to render the track.
So I'm kind of curious why you
didn't just use the track--
and you rendered the
track with Canvas--
why you don't just use that
SVG element sort of as an
image sprite and position it
and scale it as necessary?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
I mean, the reason for that is
Stewart Smith at Creative Lab
created the initial prototype
for the game.
He had done it with Paper.
And so we kind of just went off
of what he got working.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: And Paper.js
actually makes it really easy.
SVG would kind of just be raw,
you put the track on the
screen and that's kind
of all you get.
With Paper it's just an amazing
math library as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: It'll basically
give us some methods
to calculate tangents and arc
tangents and all kinds of
stuff that we need to basically
move the car each
frame and get the position
rotation x and y values.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah.
So Paper.js really helps to
cost down the track, so we
don't need to [INAUDIBLE] the
image and find out where the
points are.
We can just give it the
coordinants, like a
percentage-based [INAUDIBLE]
should be on the track and
then it puts it there.
MICHAEL ANTHONY:
Yeah, exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So it provides a lot more
features in terms of knowing
where the car is, which
direction it's
maybe traveling in.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, cool.
ANDY THELANDER: Because
I mean, SVG is
just made up of curves.
And so Paper can hook into that
and then it can calculate
for itself whereabouts
it needs to be.
So it really helped
in that aspect.
PETE LEPAGE: Right, OK.
What other things did you find
Paper was useful for?
Or what else did you
use Paper for?
Or was that sort of the
primary purpose of it?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: That was
the main purpose of it.
The other things that it was
really useful for, so
basically we had to make
the tracks fit across--
if you had an iPad and a Nexus
4 and then if you had iPhone
to the mix, the width and height
of the screen-- we can
never assume they were any
specific dimensions.
It had to work across any
combination of devices.
And Paper was awesome because
we basically had a bunch of
different tracks at different
widths to accommodate the
phones from one screen
to five screen.
But we also had to take those
and kind of stretch them a bit
and scale them to fit
any combination.
So Paper was awesome because
you could apply a scale
matrix, and it would directly
correlate to the car still
following around the path.
So it made it really, really
easy to make the car move.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, nice.
Cool, cool.
Now one of the things that
you guys did a lot of was
animations, right?
And this was a pretty
huge thing.
Talk to me a little bit about
how you animated and got good
performance so that you didn't
have any jankiness.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah, so it's
just visual chemistry almost
between the code.
So we apply CSS animations
with JavaScript.
But when you [AUDIO OUT]
so that they don't stack up
and delay each other.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
ANDY THELANDER: So you make this
nice linear path where
it's nicely step timed out in
between each animation.
For process, a heavy JavaScript
calculations, like
building the track, we've had to
refer it to CSS animations
on an infinite loop.
Just because it takes away a
little processing of applying
a tween to an object.
PETE LEPAGE: Yup.
ANDY THELANDER: And just change
class name name and it
just animates.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: What's nice
right now is that on mobile
CSS animations will run actually
in a separate thread
to the main UI.
So while JavaScript--
basically, while it was
generating that track code,
you've got your 16 milliseconds
frame budget, of
course, to get 60 frames
per second.
And I'm sure the track rendering
was taking up
probably at least 50%
to 80% of that.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So if you were
to use a JavaScript-based
time animation frame by frame,
it would be very janky.
But by using the CSS animation
it was still very smooth
because it was running
separately to the JavaScript
processing.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Now in your experience, are
there places where you would
say, I would absolutely say
you really should use
JavaScript animations verses
CSS animations and places
where you should use CSS
over JavaScript?
Because to me it's one of
those things that CSS is
almost always going
to do it better.
But are there places where
you disagree with that?
ANDY THELANDER: So yeah.
For CSS betweens we definitely
use CSS just because it takes
no processing from JavaScript,
and you can do other things in
the background.
Through JavaScript animation,
it's probably step-by-step.
So scroll sites use a
lot of JavaScript.
And Canvas automation,
obviously, you need to do it
in JavaScripts.
But that's really only
use is when we use
requstAnimationFrame
and update between
manually each frame.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: If you're just
moving things around like
in Racer when the lobby comes
in and the bars slide in,
that's CSS animation.
It's [INAUDIBLE] transitions,
actually.
It's perfect for that.
If you're doing a complex
calculation-type animation
where your using Canvas
or even some sort of--
ANDY THELANDER: Like
the loader.
The loader at the start
is all Canvas.
Those 5 lines are [INAUDIBLE]
Canvas, just tweening
a value in a
requestAnimationFrame loop.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: But the rule of
thumb is if you can use CSS
animations, absolutely do.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Cool.
That makes sense.
Well, let's talk a little
bit about what's
going back and forth.
So now that we've got the track
rendered, we've got our
positions on screen, three,
two, one, like,
it's time to go.
We've got to start touching
our screens to
make our cars go.
What data is going back
and forth in order
to track each car?
Yeah, let's start with that.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So let's
pretend we have
a two player race.
And both cars are on the
left screen to start.
And then one car moves through
the left screen and is now on
the right screen.
Every frame, or every few frames
let's say, each device
looks at which cars are actually
on the screen.
And it bundles all the
information about cars, their
position, their velocity,
their laps
positioning on the track.
If it's on that screen, it says
information out to the
other phones.
And the other phones update
their cars with that new
information.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: If the car's
not on the screen, it receives
that information from
the other phone
and updates its values.
And the reason for this
is basically when
you press the throttle--
and that's another event
that gets sent--
you touch and you turn the
throttle on that message gets
sent to all the players.
And so each phone individually
is actually rendering the
track just as if you were
playing with only one player.
But let's say it took 20
milliseconds to receive my
throttle event, but your phone
took 40 milliseconds.
So now the cars, they're going
to start at different times
and be out of sync.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: So there's a
few tricks that'll happen to
make up that difference in
time for when it starts.
But even still, as they're
moving we found that they
would kind of come out
of sync a bit.
So when the car's off screen, we
update it every four frames
or so, which actually keeps
it very, very close.
So when it comes time to
crossover from screen to
screen, it's in the
right place.
And then your phone takes
over and you see it.
And the whole things
appears smooth.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So when the car is on a
screen, that screen is
responsible for its position.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: But then when it
goes on to another screen, it
gets that data.
It says, hey where are you,
every four frames, so much
less frequently.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah, exactly.
I mean, that's the benefit of
the concept is that a car can
only appear at one
screen at a time.
So we only really need to make
sure that at that moment on
that screen it needs
to be smooth.
Whereas if it's off the screen
on your phone then it can just
jump frame by frame.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
That makes sense.
So you're obviously using
WebSockets to send data.
What is each, for lack of a
better term, packet or data
chunk look like?
What are you sending with
each particular piece?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: It's not
actually that small.
I know with Roll It those guys
are able to get it super,
super tiny [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
They got it down to, like,
maybe 20 bytes or
something like that.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah, we're
probably working with a few
more than that.
Probably not quite a kilobyte,
maybe somewhere around there.
But basically, it was just a
JavaScript object that was
converted to a shrink just with
JSON and [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: And the
object contains--
actually in some cases it
was actually pretty big.
Because when it was sent
information about car, let's
say one car had all five
screens, it would have an
array with object data with
position, velocity
for each of the cars.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: But at one
point early on I kind of
thought, all right, well
converting this object to a
string might be a little bit too
verbose and we might need
to make it smaller.
And then I started thinking
about coming up with shorthand
ways and then parsing that
on the other phones.
But to be honest, it never
quite got there.
The latency issues were solved
well before we ever had to go
down that path of
optimization.
PETE LEPAGE: Interesting.
OK.
So you've got a JSON object that
has on array with each
car which includes the velocity,
the location.
Are there any other things that
you're storing in there?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: I
think there's--
you know I'm not sure off
the to of my head.
I kind of forget.
But I think it was definitely
the velocity, the x and y
position, how far along
the path it had been.
I think that might
have been it.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
ANDY THELANDER: [INAUDIBLE],
see
whether that car is finished.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Oh, yeah.
ANDY THELANDER: That's
pretty much it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, I guess
that make sense, too.
So that's tracking
where the car is.
What about the data whether I'm
on the throttle or not,
whether I'm touching
the screen?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
That's one of the smaller
events that gets sent.
So as soon as you touch it it
just sends which player you
are, and that you throttled
on or off.
And each device then keeps--
when it receives an on event it
turns the car on, when it
sees an off event it
turns the car off.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
So that's just a single toggle
on, hey, I'm touching.
And then there's a
single toggle off
once I've stop touching.
So you're not doing a
continuous, like, I'm
touching, touching, touching,
touching, kind of thing.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Right.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
I mean, sending the less
messages the better, basically.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Cool.
And so does each device only
have one socket connection up
to the server, or are you
using multiple different
sockets, one for the location
and one for touch and
acceleration?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Nope,
just one socket.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
OK, awesome.
So then the server doesn't
really maintain
any state at all.
It's sending that data
back and forth then.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Kind of.
It is just a pass through
for the data.
But there's actually quite a
lot of state on the server
related to the game lobby,
which players are joined.
Because the server has to keep
track of the color order,
which is really important.
Because it always has to
maintain that rainbow, HSL,
blue to red.
So for each game, if someone's
blue and they leave, it needs
to make sure that blue gets
reassigned for the next person
that joins.
And also, if players join
mid-race they basically just
see a leader board until
the race is finished.
So it kind of keeps track of
all these different states.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
So you're not actually showing
them sort of a version of the
board in a small screen
or anything like that.
You're just showing them
the leader board of
who's in front first.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Right.
Yup.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Cool.
So as you guys were--
I'll just sort of mention
this as you guys
are watching at home.
Please be sure to post
your questions.
We've got a few questions that
have popped in here.
But the link is just down
there at the bottom.
As you guys were building
this, what kinds of like
performance things were
you thinking about?
And how did you approach
making sure that the
application was just fast,
it worked really well?
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah.
So something we had to really
consider was getting
animations timed right.
So when the screen goes up and
when the ready, set, go
starts, they need to be
timed and synced.
And so what we do is send out
a pulse between the devices
saying, my animation sequence
is complete, I'm ready to
animate the next sequence.
And then that pulse gets sent
to the other phones.
And then once the server
receives all of that, it sends
out the data that the phones
can now animate
the ready, set, go.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: And then,
of course, the animations
themselves are all CSS
transitions or animations.
And so that really makes
a huge difference with
performance.
And as far as rendering the cars
along the path, I mean,
that was one part that was
particularly tricky.
And what we ended up finding was
that on iOS, the smoothest
way to make the cars accelerate
was using the
translate 3D property and
a rotation transform.
On Android, the fastest way was
actually to calculate the
matrix values directly in
JavaScript, and then apply it
as a transform matrix.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
So a little bit of experimenting
with each of the
different platforms to make sure
that you've got the best
performance.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Lots
of experimenting.
When they demoed it at I/O, we
were there and we saw it a few
days before.
And what happened was they
plugged in video out from each
device, which I'm sure everybody
who's done screen
capture realizes that it
actually saps the power off
the devices because now it has
to render two screens.
He actually had to, like, the
night before kind of figure
out-- and that's when
we figured out the
whole matrix thing.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Was because,
OK, now it looks kind of
choppy because the video
out-- and so we had to
kind of solve that.
PETE LEPAGE: Those are
always the fun,
pre-keynote kinds of things--
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yes.
PETE LEPAGE: --and good
little story for
folks who are watching.
So there's a question that was
posted in Google Moderator,
and it's from the Florian
in France.
And I'll take a stab
at answering this.
But on Android, Web Audio
support is behind a flag in
Chrome Beta right now.
When's it going to
be available for
all users in stable?
And Florian, it's coming soon.
We don't have a specific
date on it yet.
There's a bunch of sort of
little technical things that
we're just trying to make sure
that works really well across
all devices.
So there's a set of device--
I think it's part of the CPU
that's required in order to be
able to use Web Audio.
And so we're just making sure
that for devices that have it,
we've got a great experience,
and devices that don't have
it, that we have a reasonable
fallback experience, that
there's not going to
be anything sort
of awkward in there.
So please keep posting
your questions.
I'm kind of curious a little bit
for Michael and Andy about
your workflow in terms of how
you went from the prototypes
and that stuff to the tools
that you used and how you
actually got everything
up to the server.
What was that process like?
ANDY THELANDER: So in terms of
what programs we used, we used
[INAUDIBLE]
Studio for an [? ID ?],
SourceTree through Git, and
[INAUDIBLE]
machines.
But in terms of how we operate,
when we're developing
for mobile we usually do it on
the desktop just because we
find that's the quickest way
to refresh and just quickly
iterate on our code.
So for this particular project,
to simulate multiple
devices we had to do multiple
browser windows.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
ANDY THELANDER: That worked
really well, just because we
could line them up like you
would in an array of devices.
And we just set a flag in our
code, that force mobile, and
we can force the mobile layout
and it's the same as multiple
mobile devices.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Right.
Yeah, until it actually
was ready to deploy.
And then you test the
[INAUDIBLE] devices and your
like, ah, that animation is
too complex for mobile and
kind of tweak it a bit.
But then we eventually had
this massive array.
We had a table just next to our
desks with this huge array
of devices.
We had all kinds of Android
and iOS devices.
And we put them in order.
And we'd try one player
to five player to
everything in between.
And we would work that way.
We have a noJS solution that
we kind of whipped up that
basically when we do console.log
on the device,
it'll turn up in our desktop
Chrome Console and we can
inspect objects and such.
PETE LEPAGE: Ah, interesting.
How did you do that?
What was involved in that?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: It's just a
simple Socket.IO noJS server.
On the front end it includes a
script that has Socket.IO.
just a tiny bit of logic, and
just a small bit of logic on
the server that basically
says--
on the mobile device it kind
of hijacks console.log.
And instead of doing the
normal thing, in sends
whatever that message was just
to a socket server, which gets
routed to the desktop version
that knows it's desktop, and
it just consoles out
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: So there you can
actually see what's going on
on each of the different
devices.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
It was much easier that way than
using the Android remote
debugging, because that
would only work on
one device at a time.
In this case we had five.
But there were times
where we did--
OK, we have a rendering issue.
We need to see what's
going on.
And we'd plug in an Android
device to the remote inspector
and kind of look at the
time-line panel and see where
the paint was, that
sort of thing.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Interesting.
Di you use any other tools
to help on the mobile?
So anything like Adobe's Edge or
any of the other automation
tools or even the Chrome
Developer Tools for mobile?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: We did use the
Chrome Developer Tools for
mobile quite a bit.
We didn't use Adobe Edge.
I'd actually like to give that
a try at some point.
I'm actually working on
a little mobile app--
I guess it's similar to Adobe
Edge just because we do a few
things kind of weird internally
that would just
automate our process.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Cool, cool.
That's somewhat useful.
Of the Chrome Developer Tools,
did you find you used any of
the emulation features?
of the Chrome Developer Tools on
desktop to try and see how
things would behave on mobile?
MICHAEL ANTHONY:
No, we didn't.
You just relied on the
devices themselves.
Because in this case, we
actually had them all.
If we didn't have them all,
we probably would do that.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So I guess I've got one other
question for you.
Well, I've got two.
Of all of the tools that you
guys have used and all of the
APIs and the stuff that's
available on the web, so
anything you wish you had today
that is not available
that would have made
your lives easier?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Being able to
know if the device has fallen
asleep or not.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: It sounds
simple, but it actually is
really kind of complex,
especially when dealing with
WebSockets.
Because if the device just falls
asleep on its own, or
let's say you get a phone call
in the middle of the game, the
game's broken because your part
of the track is missing.
So we need to send an event to
tell everybody, hey, you've
got to start over.
But the problem is when the
browser goes to sleep, it
doesn't actually close
the WebSocket so
there's no way to know.
And so what we had to do is on
the server keep track of
basically pulse events.
Because it would stop sending
events, but the socket would
remain open.
So if it did receive a pulse for
a certain amount of time,
it would basically say, OK, this
device is disconnected.
And also on the client side,
basically every frame we
checked the time stamp and how
long they'd been since the
last frame executed.
So if it's been a few seconds,
you know the
device has fallen asleep.
And then you can show the
message saying you need to
refresh the page.
PETE LEPAGE: That's an
interesting one.
And I've not heard of any
discussions of that.
I would encourage you--
and any time as a developer if
you're watching this show and
you're working on something and
your like, I wish I had
this feature, go file a bug
on the Chromium bugs list.
new.crbug.com is the easiest
way to get a bug filed.
new.mcrbug.com is a quick, easy
way to get a bug filed
for mobile Chrome.
But that's a great
feature request.
And that's something that I'll
take back to the team and
we'll definitely look into.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Cool.
PETE LEPAGE: So my last question
for you guys, kind of
an easy one, what was
your high score?
What do we need to beat
while trying to play?
ANDY THELANDER: Just don't
fly off the track.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: Yeah.
ANDY THELANDER: We got pretty
good at playing the game.
If you tap right before you go
through a corner, it doesn't
fly off the track.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: That might
be how we coded it.
We're not too sure.
But, yeah, that's [INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: Not that
you're giving away,
like, any secret hints.
Or actually--
OK, one more question.
Any good cheats or anything like
that developers should be
aware of that they
can play with?
MICHAEL ANTHONY: I don't think
there's any cheats.
ANDY THELANDER: Yeah, no
Easter eggs there.
MICHAEL ANTHONY: It's more like,
if you tap and release
at a steady interval, you're
not going to fly off.
You're going to give up a little
bit of maximum speed,
but you're going to
be safer that way.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Awesome.
Well, guys thank you very,
very much for joining us.
For those of you who are
watching at home, you should
definitely check out the
game at g.co/racer.
And you should check out the
"HTML5 Rocks" article that
these guys wrote.
It was really good, really
interesting.
I learned a little bit.
I thought it was a fascinating
article to
get behind the scenes.
So with that, I want
to say thanks
everybody for joining us.
Thanks to Michael and Andy for
joining us and getting up
early in LA this morning.
ANDY THELANDER: Nice.
[INAUDIBLE].
PETE LEPAGE: And thanks
everybody.
Have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]